Google of course is one of several big
tech monopolies and not the only one
worth worrying about Amazon if you can
believe it an even larger company than
google despite being worth a trillion
dollars many of its half a million
employees live in poverty Shannon Allen
is one of them she's an Amazon employee
says she's been living out of her car
and she joins us tonight Shannon thanks
very much for coming on how can you work
for the richest man in the world and and
live out of your car it doesn't make any
sense
well what happened was is when they
first when I first got injured I went on
medical leave three weeks after my
injury and the checks were delayed
coming in and then after the checks
started coming in they hurried up
through my process of me being injured
and sent me back to work early so then
that took some time to work and get some
hours in to where I got a paycheck from
Amazon again and when I was reinjure
died went back out on medical leave in
January and just to be clear you were
injured on the job you say and then you
wound up living in your car yes I
started living in my car several months
ago because of non-payment from the
workers comp and from Amazon so so we
spoke to Amazon and we should say in the
interest of fairness that they say they
offered you a lump sum cash payment is
that true they did they did offer me
$3,500 after the first year you were
offered $2,000 to quit and then they
offered me an extra $1,500 in Cobra
payments for my medical injury that I
still have and I declined that offer
because you have to sign a nondisclosure
agreement which also means that you
can't talk about the inside workings of
Amazon you can't talk about how much
money you received
or you can't sue them you can't collect
unemployment and you can't use your
First Amendment right to speak out about
any type of experience you had at Amazon
and my First Amendment right is worth
more than $3,500 well we're glad you're
here telling us about it
so again just for our viewers just
tuning in you are an employee of a of
Amazon one of the biggest companies the
world trillion dollar market cap and
you're living in your car your story
can't be the average story but do you
know other Amazon employees who are in
effect in poverty I actually I do I had
a guy from Madrid Spain contact me on
Twitter and let me in sent me a video
telling me that he is in the exact same
position that he was injured at Amazon
and then terminated from his job and he
is now homeless also there's also other
employees right in hazlet Texas at the
same facility that I work at that are
also having a hard time making ends meet
when workers comp wants to pay $7 or
Amazon wants to pay you $7 a week we
can't make it on $7 a week and I would
workers to come forward and you know if
they have any questions or comments or
want to contact me I want them to come
forward and and contact me we're
interested in hearing from them as well
we're interested in this story it does
seem odd that one of the richest
companies will run by the richest man in
the world who advocates for socialism at
taxpayer expense would have employees
who are living in their cars Shannon
thank you very much thank you good to
talk to you